[Musique]
pierre cottensault je suis le Directeur
technique adjoint de safran aft engine
en charge des moteurs pour avion de
ligne
[Musique]
le programme Rice est un programme de
démonstration technologique pour
concevoir les moteurs d'avion de ligne
du futur envoie derrière moi une
maquette de cet Open fan de ce
démonstrateur rise c'est une maquette à
l'échelle 1/2 la taille réelle de
l'hélice ce sera environ 4 mètres de
diamètre et l'hélice est constituée de
deux ensembles une hélice qui tourne
devant et une hélice fixe derrière
[Musique]
le principe c'est pour réduire la
consommation de carburant on intérêt à
brasser le plus d'air possible dans le
moteur et donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait
une hélice beaucoup plus grande que les
moteurs d'aujourd'hui notre objectif
c'est de faire 20% de consommation en
moins par rapport à nos meilleurs
moteurs d'aujourd'hui les lips qui
eux-mêmes avaient réduit la consommation
de 15% par rapport à la génération
précédente ce moteur permettra de
réduire la consommation en carburant en
augmentant le débit d'air dans le moteur
les lois de la physique nous disent que
c'est plus efficace pour propulser un
avion
[Musique]
bureau d'études de safran attrapengine
qui conçoit ce moteur il est
principalement localisé à Villaroche
près de Melun mais on reçoit également
le support de nombreux établissements de
safran notamment celui de safrantech à
Magny-les-Hameaux qui inclut notamment
des ingénieurs spécialisés en
aérodynamique en matériaux qui viennent
soutenir les équipes de sa première
craft engine localisé à villarrosse à
l'ingénierie on recrute des ingénieurs
des techniciens pour concevoir les
moteurs de demain les moteurs qui
permettront de réaliser les objectifs de
transport aérien moins carboné à
l'horizon 2050